the mastering the middlegame
I was thinking who masters the
middlegame and there's the obvious
answer Karpov and then I was like what's
Karpov good at and I was like
gentlemanly club life no he doesn't go
to Yale like Matt Larson so the correct
answer was the clothes real Lopez okay
and if you thought you were bored
earlier with the lecture weights leads
to this lecture I'm not a big fan of the
closed ruie in the national open about
three years ago I decided in the last
round because you know when you're
playing for money in the last John you
should make no weird decisions I was
like I've never had white in a closed
room
never I got black kind of clothes really
like once every three years every four
years so I was like okay I'll have white
to close drooly if possible and I played
the real apes' with white and I was like
how cool and I won in like 40 moves my
opponent said why you really understood
the opening I went what you actually
said that has like I I move three I was
done
okay so Karpov is pretty good three
Lopes and since I'm older than everybody
/ Karpov I've seen a lot of car pubs
games so I have some understanding now I
didn't do the Berlin and I didn't do the
open Rui or the Marshall or anything so
it's just closed right now I'm very
opinionated as you know and let's say
you're playing Kasparov okay which I
guess you probably should wake up at
that point so you're playing Kasparov
and you're like mmm what should I do
you're like well I know I'll play sharp
theoretical line I don't know that he
does and then he plays out novelty and
he checkmates you and takes all your
pieces because he calculates and you
don't and he knows the theory and you
don't that seems like a bad idea
so most grandmasters that I know who are
are so stupid they play just like that
so you see lots of Kasparov games where
that's what he does and then he retired
because it was too easy okay
and I'm usually not guilty of this
usually I'm like okay
this is the guy I'm playing this is what
he's good at this is what he's bad at
and then I do what he's bad at you guys
luckily make it easy so the last game
that I lost that was rated what - Sam
Savion the reason I'm saying this is I'm
going to lose a lot of games in the next
couple weeks so I haven't lost in 17
months that I'm going to lose like three
or four games in the next like three
weeks because I'm playing at a normal
tournament here where I'm gonna play a
lot of good players and when I played
Sam seven I was black at a very sharp
Sicilian not a good idea and I've done
that before I was black against left
Milman and a sharp Sicilian also lost
all my pieces and I remember telling you
a story earlier today in this restaurant
- Matthew Larson and matt said who's
left Milman some Josie what I know
so of course you would hold on the
middle have Milman is because what do
you know but he was a good player he was
IMG em depending on who you ask
2500 feet a and doesn't really play much
anymore okay so okay so speaking of the
Chicago Hope and which I wasn't speaking
of Matthew Larson got his first I am
norm with two rounds to go and of course
that means you want nobody you did half
a point more for a thousand but didn't
get it and if he had won round eight he
would have got a grandmaster norm was
around ago but he lost ground eight drew
round nine and okay got a norm which is
pretty good and he was querying me am I
the only person born in st. Louis living
in st. Louis's got it ever gotten I am
norm and I was like I think so yeah we
don't have a lot of I am born and bred
yeah anybody disagree you guys aren't
from here anyway so you don't know okay
so John were you born here yeah I didn't
think so your your only hope
okay you were yeah but yeah but I know
Claudia ones what's that you were born
here and say Louis yeah and then yeah
and then you woke up and apologized okay
now the reason I mentioned the Chicago
pin is one of our own Talia servantes
interesting sure Weston okay yeah she
scored reasonably well not great
reasonably well seven out of seven now
those of you who just walked in there
like no don't call I me what percentage
is that seven out of seven yeah and she
won drum roll I never get a good drum
roll here how about you at home yeah
that's good
five grand okay but she's from Cuba and
then taxes so I think like she lost
money I so yeah some of the locals that
come here to the club all the time
they're killing it and Talia is going to
be playing in the chess calm nonsense
tournament they're having next week
that's the official name right yeah I
think the nonsense tournament all right
so every game starts the same way the
first nine moves so the nine moves are
the real Lopez which in Europe is called
the Spanish opening and in probably
every other country hey what do they
call it in South America Spanish the
reuleaux cuz man is America sitting
together yeah there you go okay so we
got the closed ruie every close drew he
ever starts like this now earlier I was
complaining that when people play
Kasparov when he was good and they would
go into these long sharp complicated
lines and then he would crush them and
then I was making fun of them for
playing in such a style and when I
wanted to advocate because this is a
real Lopez Karpov lecture is you should
play like kramnik did Kramnik actually
had the correct strategy trade all the
pieces and make the game very boring and
play something that wasn't very
theoretical now sing that Berlin isn't
theoretical now doesn't make a lot of
sense but it did 20 years ago when it
wasn't very theoretical okay so now
everybody plays the Berlin basically
because of that match now what point am
I making I don't know no I do no point
I'm making is Karpov was very good at
being slightly better carolina-style
right John
and then slowly but surely winning the
game in a million moves now of course I
don't want to lecture more than 10 or 15
minutes right you agree you want to hear
me to Eternia and so if I look at some
of carp rods games they're 90 moves and
move 80s till the middle game and I'm
like he's still maneuvering his upon a
fell asleep and he turned the clock okay
then people here like what's this that's
the old clocks the end ok anyway so I
found some games that he won in 20 30 40
moves over his career in this position
and my point the whole point was if
you're playing Karpov you shouldn't be
black and a closed real Lopez that's not
a good idea that's the that's the thing
he's the best at ok and it's this well
known all right now this is a Spassky
who's also quite good
and this was in the 70s when Spassky was
quite good and he played the the breyer
a brayer depends what kind of ice cream
you like all right
so Karpov facing the breyer ice cream
variation night ba now this is a very
good variation if you're going to lose
the game quickly why because you're
saying your pieces back up so you've got
night ba right you're all set
ok just a few more pieces and you set up
ok and the point of night be it is
obvious the blacks going to put the
night on d7 the Bishop on b7 and the
bishops not blocked anymore and
sometimes when white plays d5 we play C
6 attacking the pawn and sometimes the
night goes to c5 and attacks the bishop
so that's the whole point of the
variation Spassky was playing this since
before Breyer was born should we call
the Spassky variation which is funny
because I think Breyer died before
Spassky was born how does he make any
sense all right so they now usually we
play d4 in players today like God a calm
ski will play the Breyer still if I
remember correctly and I don't
there was the game from the US
Championship Wesley so vs. gotta calm
ski and I assume Wesley play d4 but what
do I know
yeah ok so Karpov played D 3 because
that's more boring ok so you got to play
as boring as possible okay so nobody
does anything and we're going to master
the middle game what Karpov likes to do
is not give you an e counter play and
eventually he gets played but not too
much don't have too much of an advantage
because Carla Juana wouldn't like that
ok and when we play 92
what's the idea what's the landing
square for our night
Knight f1 is not that's the next square
then what G three threes would you then
f5 and then mate prior okay so the
problem is Karpov is not thinking about
his plan all the time he's thinking
about what blacks plan is and then his
opponents don't have any plans because
he stops all of them
all right so night f1 95
should we let black take this bishop no
the ships are good when your rating goes
up you'll like bishops more so million
one or two of you like this ships the
other like Claudia likes bishops and
that's about it okay there ask you like
what about Knights I play a lot of
bughouse
okay so rook e8 because you should
always play bishop fa a-- it's basically
do that
okay now that Knights too active it's
too good okay so just like Cara wanna
say b3 again idea a double dare you say
be free again okay b4 there we go okay
and the night goes back and then they
agreed to a draw caz white played b2 and
the ninety five and repetition now okay
and now he played d4 hah
when you least expects it okay so now
when you see these three pieces in the
were Lopez and you see those a lot
then this pawn is hanging a lot of the
time because there's a lot of guys that
are going to be on that pawn but you
notice before you play d4 Karpov played
nine g3 so if he was like I'll play d4
and then I'll do this at some point
maybe when the night gets to f1 you'll
lose your e4 pawn but now you won't
because it affords defended okay now
Stan she's not going back to c5 because
there's two pawns that can take it even
if he misses one of them he's okay all
right h6 put it in H now what's the most
boring move ever it's the move I forbid
most of my students to play luckily
Karpov is not my student Bishop d2 yeah
as boring as possible yeah you got to
play boring
okay now the bishop on d2 defends these
pawns which may be attacked after some
trades and we let our work get out
because our bishop on c1 was blocking
our rook and Spassky played 9th b6
because he
make night maneuvers also like goes to
c4 and when you see pawns on these color
complex the dark squares you try to put
pieces on the white squares okay now
remember Karpov rule is you never move a
piece more than one square because the
opponent might get scared
so Bishop to d3 all right there we go
okay so the bishop on f8 wants to be
Fein cathode so g6 Queen c2 that's one
square that's enough Knight FG seven and
now he broke his rule with rook ad one a
lot of times of the real Lopes we play
a4 and we do stuff and you'll see that
in future games but with the night on b6
that's hard to do okay but rooks are
good in the center so I like the way all
car pops pieces are next to each other
the ones that have the same that way he
could really recognize them okay Bishop
g7 and now the game's not boring enough
so Karpov made him more boring he took
on e5 he wants to open up the D file and
if Spassky takes with a piece do some
more trading or I left d4 for his ninth
while me I would probably take with a
knight but okay he played pawn takes
okay now when I do game analysis for the
same field cop and us championship and
us jr. I have a very important rule of
thumb which seems to be correct most of
the time when they start playing crazy
in the opening the game is a boring draw
later and when they start playing boring
like this then it gets all exciting okay
they get just play one way the whole
game so this is a really boring game
nothing's happening and White's a tiny
bit better because I don't know this
rooks not very good then this rooks
opposite your queen now this bishop sort
of blocked I don't know why this Knight
is here it can't really move anywhere so
okay so now Karpov decides it's time to
strike there's no more boring moves and
he plays C 4 which is explosive right
okay and well if white plays c5 and it
actually is explosive so okay we have to
take that and now Karpov gives away the
two bishops because he weakens his
opponent's pawn structure
Karpov likes when you have permanent
weaknesses
you have two isolated plans Karpov has
no isolated plans now if I was playing a
blitz game or a slow game I would play
Knight takes e4 and in fact I I don't
even understand why he didn't do that
because that bishops really good even if
it's a good trade for white I still do
it because the bishops too good so I
would I would take on c4 all day I don't
care if it hangs my queen okay I'm
annamund okay so I queen e7 to be is
crazy so I guess that's why he lost in
in ten more moves so Queen seven Karpov
saves his Bishop the ship on b3 so I
really don't like Queen e7 I'm going to
call it the losing move even if it's
like best you can use your computer at
home okay and the reason you play Queen
e7 is yes to get rid of his isolated
pawns if he doesn't and trades on c4 why
it's going to take
why don't play Bishop e3 you'll never
play c5 and your pawn will be on c7 weak
the whole game on an open file and
you're not going to play c6 blocking
your bishop because that's too many
arrows so you're not allowed to yeah
these guys were good it was the early
70s but they knew that computers would
come and have arrows everywhere okay so
Queen e7 and c5 now earlier in the
lecture I was like when the rooks on a1
we play a four open up the file
well here Spassky wants to either take
this or place for attacking the bishop
so car buff plays a4 and he says well if
you play c4 I'm going to retreat and if
you don't play c4 I'm going to go here
and the Black Knight has a lot of nice
squares right no no the Knights terrible
okay so Spassky played c4 and then he
played Bishop c6 and Bishop a4
haha masky sneaky okay unfortunately he
might win some material but he's losing
the yeah he's losing everything
so in this idea we're skewering our
knight as a safe square unfortunately
this is hanging in weak
this is hanging in a week and the other
black pieces are very passive and I have
two rules for my opponents for my
opponents for my students they seem like
my opponents one is you're not allowed
to sacrifice and the second is the
funniest answer is obviously always
sacrifice yeah that's the funniest
answer but the correct answer is
sacrificing the exchange is not
sacrificing okay because when you lose
the exchange you lose a rook for a minor
piece and a rook and a minor piece or
each one piece so you're not sacrificing
anything if you give a night away that
you don't have your night we can do like
go into a Chess Club and find a night
okay so Queen c1 he's like you can have
my rook I'm going to take this I'm going
to take this I'm going to take this okay
now the rooks not running away so he
moved his Knight away
yum-yum-yum took the rook now the rook
is running away so take it and now White
has a pawn for the exchange blacks loss
to King side pawn and black sea pawn is
going to be lost and blacks pieces are
all terrible so in the opening and
middle game I would say usually a minor
piece is better than a ruck a little bit
especially the first 10 moves when the
rooks are in the corner not moving at
the end of the game when the guys are
work on the seventh and your Knight
can't move then then they work then the
rook is better so well remember when
black played aged six now White's going
to play Knight g5 and White's could play
Bishop c4 and blacks going to be really
unhappy
so in this middle game blacks minor
pieces are much worse than whites and
even though black has an extra ruck as
Dominique Meyers would say my good
friend when I asked him why did you lose
that rook he said I have another one so
okay so but white lost her rook but he
has another one and I don't I'm not a
big fan of these rooks okay the game
ended very quickly putting on training
so you guys at home can see okay 96
defending the C pawn oh no he did
and also the nyancy it was terrible I
can move my rook Bishop g7 this is a
good question for the class what a black
do I thought it was good how about you
at home now you don't know either you
get back there
don't leave Darien yeah I thought the
class would get there but they're slow
on the uptake okay
Queen g5 Queen g5 is a funny move
because usually you don't think of
trading pieces when you're down material
but this rook is attacking a lot of
nights so if you trade Queens you're not
going to do well with your Knights for
example takes takes and you you can't
even defend your night with rookie six
there's a knight here so now there's a
lot of nights hanging yeah that's not
good
okay so Spassky broke my rule that's
what you know the game is going to end
soon
five six although let's play another
move and show great tactics to the class
Queen e6 yeah
rook takes d6 the Knight f5 check is
good for white okay so f6 sort of forced
queen g4 now once again we're
threatening rook takes Knight and Knight
f5 check so that's not good anyway I
want to point out this rooks doing a
good job over here defending this pawn
so White's not going to win that pawn if
you were worried some of you were like
what if he loses the a pawn and white
has to pass pawns
no no it's fine don't don't worry about
it okay so this is the best trick I've
ever seen these nights are pretty good
right and this queen is all over them
and if the knight moves away from d6
bishops a monster and black is like no
leave me alone okay King h7 which stops
my threat darn I wanted to play rook
takes a knight f5 okay and Knight h4 now
a shocking development happened
he resigned yeah I was like resigned and
I was like well okay wait no I only
found one move that I would actually
make I was like nah I can't go that
can't do that can't do that
then I found a move that I thought was
like sort of okay anyone what does black
do about all this g6 stuff yeah that's
what white does yeah that's what white
wants to buzz black Stern how does black
stop that
yeah well he's talked to better than you
guys he resigned yeah I thought rook GA
and Knight f8 is also also possible yeah
so after either Knight f8 or rogue g8
you you can play Knight to g6 which
surprised me but it really shouldn't
have so for example let's play here I
don't know okay so 96 that's annoying
now what we take a yeah
okay and then check and then you go here
I assume yeah what's that the knight
would take it that's why I took it yeah
see you forgot it was there and then I
was like wow this is really good for
Wyatt because that moves going to happen
next move and I was like I'm not taking
black here it's funny because if the
King retreats my bishops going to be
good all of a sudden yeah so it was
funny in this position where he resigned
also this was the same rig ga was the
same rig ga was also this I was like wow
yeah
and then after rook takes what was the
winning move was like Queen here and you
sack everything whenever if you're cheat
it wasn't a g6 I thought it was hmm
confused
I was I supposed to win
actually that is annoying this should
take c4 as you can't take my bishop
because this is good for white and then
your rucks attacked yeah
and now if you play route g7 you might
get checkmated probably play Knight f5
here lose a funny variation unless you
have black then it's slightly less funny
yeah but but you guys were still worried
about that I told you not to be I told
you I told you it's okay so there was a
really good example of using all of your
pieces to attack and just getting a big
positional advantage and sacrificing the
exchange so after 9h four I wasn't
convinced so I turned the engine on then
I was convinced the engine says six
point five for Wyatt I was like wow the
engine really likes white and it defends
great for black and I was like all right
I give up
yeah yeah see Karpov used to be good and
you know things happened okay so that
was one of my favorite Karpov victories
this is a famous victory too because
they played the opening and then his
opponent resigned so the middle game
lasted like one move now Lou Lutz today
asked me what is the middle game I was
like I don't know she's like when does
it start
it's like as it moved 10 and I was like
I don't know I get something I don't
know until she stopped so well sometimes
the middle game is moved 25 and
sometimes it's move 7 I'm not sure the
middle game starts was the MIL game
start there
alright so somehow these moves were
played because they were played in every
game we're looking at today ok and then
black resigned may have Karpov is good
at this opening no ok so 98 was the last
game and he played night a 5 which I've
played and not with good results ok and
now do we let him take now you never do
okay and the point of night a 5
when the night goes to be eight we play
Knight d7 Bishop here well then I go is
day five we can play C five which is
somewhat illegal in this position and
then you're not gonna go back to c6
later if you feel like it sometimes you
do sometimes you don't and black has
sort of a bind on the center which was
why
you lasted ten more moves okay D four
and now black can play more than one
move some people take on d4 now some
people put this trip to b7 some play
Bishop to d7 Queen c7 and I've had black
in this position but I forgot what
happened and when I said I forgot what
happened I remember what happened okay
okay Knight BD to the usual Karpov you
know kind of stuff good idea for his
opponent to do this against him
57 9f one rookie a d5 now in the last
lecture with Jonathan sean's the center
was closed and white started taking on
the Kings side and why made it black and
then the audience was like why didn't
wide open the center and lose okay so
when the center is closed and nobody can
do anything that you can make your
opponent will you try to make sure your
opponent the center is open then things
happen to the center and you turn your
head you hurt your neck there's no
insurance nowadays and you lose yeah
okay
this isn't 75 they knew about all that
okay so d5 close to the center knight c6
isn't going to happen and black was
really ready to take on d4 in fact when
I'm black in these positions 20 years
ago I would take on d4 take on d4 and
then I control the C file before my
opponent wrestles it from me but I have
it for a little while and then your
knight can go back and your knight could
go to b4 sometimes because the pawn took
now black and do any of that now black
has to outplay Karpov strategically okay
so Knight b7 that's a good square for
the knight where's the night going
somebody tell me what Black's next two
moves are c4 explosive at night c5 okay
the Knights okay Knight H - okay so why
it's going to get all his knights over
here and he's going to get his Queen
over here as bishop over here is rook
over here and with all those red arrows
black resigns and always we're sense of
humor
okay g6 boo what rule does that break
normally the answer would be don't play
g6
my kind of rules but that's not the rule
I have no such rule anyone it's not even
my rule I'm not even stealing it it's
just a normal rule nothing like 20 you
in here come on somebody know something
Jonathan sean's what's the rule there
are two doors in here yeah double pawns
in front of your king so don't do that
now if this bishop was on g7 already I
give them a pass okay but I can't do it
now because the bishops on e7 when my
students make these moves where they
want a fee and kind of their bishop they
have to fee and keto their bishop so
since the bishops not here that's I
don't you're not allowed to do that you
just weakened all the doors okay all
right Jim Morrison died in 71 you check
on that would you okay so we're going to
open the door to the black King and
we're going to break on through to the
other side all right like tool you got
that okay
so 9 G 3 what a shocking move the games
get in soon so don't don't blink okay c4
why play g6 then c4 why play g6 before
Knight G that could ever Mike ok f4 r r
now teach him to play g6 this one was on
g7 I wouldn't really mind f4 but with on
that but on e7 i don't i don't like f4
takes never trade bishop takes and now
again i don't know about these pieces i
know about this piece this piece this
one this one yeah i know about like you
know breaking through and also the
bishop on e7 and usually when you play
g6 you've already played Bishop f8 as in
our previous game then White's going to
play e5 that's annoying no stop ok the
ship f8 finally Bishop g5 hmm
the night has a lot of good retreat
squares okay now usually when people
hang all their pieces I'm not talking
about all of you you put a piece out
you're pulling to tax it and there's
nowhere to go you like oh yeah usually
when the Nightside f6 you got like a
pawn on g7 and a bishop on e7 and a
queen on d8 and the night on b7 is on d7
and then you're like yeah so now the
Knights defended by nothing and it's on
an open F file and probably he didn't
see Bishop g5 because white just played
Bishop f4 and he was like no my queen
then he's like yeah yeah you could have
your queen caught ball doesn't want a
Queenie once a night he doesn't want it
to be too easy okay so where's that
night going can I attack it with like
Queen f3 and rook F one man the truth
hurts okay Bishop back to e7 and then
Bishop f4 they agreed to a draw now
Queen d2
because the bishop wasn't defend as
there was discovered attack Bishop c8
there you go there's somebody who comes
to my lectures okay so the bishops well
defended the knight can now go to g7
finally has a retreat Square rook F 197
see that's that's mastering the middle
game there you go
you play Bishop f8 then back to e7 then
you play Bishop d7 back to c8
then you play Knight f5 back to b7 you
never move this rook
this guy's like world-class player -
like that wasn't a joke the only thing I
said that wasn't a joke this lecture
blacks good player but Karpov was good
9g for now if you were better at chess
for example Caruana
who was just lectured on you would
really like whites position like you
really like it now but if you were
Carolina you really like whites position
he's never a position that's good ever
and his whole life and black did what
any good Grandmaster would do he
resigned here yeah cuz what what
going on over here what's happening how
did that happen
no yeah now what it black do wrong
probably g6 was wrong probably 97 was
rather like a little wrong but the main
thing he did wrong is Karpov at his near
his peak where his favorite opening and
then he like plays it badly like black
does and then just all over that's
mastering the middle game open flout of
the King all pieces cooperating in the
attack and blacks piece is ridiculous
and Karpov actually played the rule up
has the black a lot although most of
those games were draws okay so with
black he could barely draw playing
perfect so that's why nowadays we don't
see a lot of black in these kind of real
low passes because Fischer was crushing
people Karpov was crushing people and
you see like Wesley Silver's is calm ski
and that's not making you want to play
it either so you're just like well why
am I playing the quarry when I can play
the Berlin and be equal or better that
okay and we'll do one last game because
Ben Simon's insistent
he's like I didn't do nothing that belly
I asked you have a funny story
don't edit this out although you might
if I give it was like my bullring you
rented it out okay but Bally ops he came
to the front desk of the Chess Club
because he was working with do you guys
know anything he was coaching one of the
players this thing feel Cup no mvl two
years ago and they're like we help you
this is a membership club dad here like
you know who are you yeah all right well
the front essence of a Yoshi is
especially now because you know when he
was famous it was before they were all
born and it really was before they were
all born okay so Bally offski used to be
good even though you haven't heard of
him he was a candidate for the World
Championship and in the candidates
matches where he was doing well he lost
to close the other one Kasparov yeah
kiss raucous par oh yeah nollie ask you
is pretty good now a ski played the
greatest who ever against me to make me
resign that was a really great move he
played he was winning anyway but he
really hammered me with the last move
okay so somehow they got
to this position because that's our
starting position and which we call in
Russian tibia there you go okay and
belly offski always plays the the right
now there's a grandmaster you've never
heard of Tony miles and we almost looked
at his game okay and Tony miles I used
to hang out with him occasionally and we
lived in Europe and he told me some
funny stories and I can't tell you any
of them except this one man cuz I would
go to jail okay anyway he told me and he
can't get in trouble anymore for obvious
reasons okay and he told me he was
playing ballet off ski so he went to his
internet computer whatever they do you
know and he was like mmm le ah ski he
plays the rider drew Lopez and he was
like he is zero out of his life he's
like whoo
okay he's like he's I and he actually
said zero he says he told me never drew
a game that he saw couldn't find it gave
me drew he's like well I don't play e4
but I'm playing e4 now and Myles play d4
and there was a prior rule apes' so I
was playing a guy who doesn't play
before they play you for I'd be like why
you know but again lalalalala and he
said baleog is queen God said shade and
was trapped and couldn't move and he say
I just carvalho he's like it's great so
that's how Myles prepared for his
opponents okay so but also get the last
laugh
haha anybody know he's alive okay so d4
this looks familiar except carbot played
e3 last time all right so they're
playing the main main main line putting
everybody to sleep this was a 90 92 sort
of the end of when Karpov was crushing
everybody
although 94 was this peak rating okay
what do you know this should buffet and
I think this is actually a lot of games
now yeah they're still playing a for
Bishop d3 yeah this is like a lot of
games yeah since this was played in 1992
the recording games from the 70s and 80s
but they're still playing this way so
the pawns attacked c6 yeah this is every
game ever played ever by everybody now
they're quoting all these games
in the notes spassky's blacken all of
them even the ones he's not okay Bishop
g7 now I'm not seeing that Bally offski
is a great attacking player which he is
and he's really good at sharp positions
which he is but why is he playing boring
slightly worst against Karpov terrible
so Bally ASCII actually is good at
complicated tactical comp
that's what he should be doing he
shouldn't be slightly worse and trying
to defend and draw terrible okay so
they're quoting a game from a million
years ago where Queen b6 was played and
Bally ASCII played died aged 5 and
you're always told by your teacher shows
the kind of teacher you have don't put
your pieces on the side or are but the
reason to put the piece on the side is
then it can go in the center that's in
the center can't go there it's already
there so you got to go away from this
and then go towards the center confusing
your opponent so of course when you see
pawn structures you try to find squares
your pieces can go to where they can't
be captured okay here your piece is
captured here here right you go you go
here I'm going to capture you yeah okay
but what about there all right at four
okay so nine h5 def for very common
another reason to play it is you open up
your Bishop which is blocked by your
knight and now it's not man Valley ops
key is good by this time in the game
loons liquor was like can I resign now
and this is just like normal position so
okay always play mission f1 good now
Knight f4 isn't so annoying because it's
not attacking the bishop then we could
just kick it out so Dinah for like I
don't care
play that a for I dare you I double dare
you okay Queen b6 b4 and both players
fell asleep Karpov won on time yeah
Knight f4 and Karpov did it again wait
he won last time that's why I did it
again he took on e5 he always does that
before his opponents can take and like
open up the e-file for the rook okay now
in the previous game which we saw D
takes e5 c4 and then white one in like
25 moves
okay so Belyaev skis like none all on
active pieces
Knight takes e5 yay look at all my
active pieces the problem with taking
with a pawn is you block all of your
pieces your night on d7 your Bishop on
g7 you look on ei so he's like I'm
taking with a knight in the previous the
two games ago when he took with a pawn I
would have taken with a knight I don't
like when my pieces are inactive okay
but Karpov is like no no no you're taken
with a pawn and now ya taking what the
Bishop of the rook looks risky because I
can do this and then like slap you and
stuff
that gives me my pawns and attack your
pieces my knight can attack on f3 your
d6 pawn is weak for ever an open file so
this actually makes some sense to me
okay and then c4 rawr okay again in all
these positions when White's playing c5
or winning upon he's doing well and then
like an Atlantic Queen's Gambit
positions even though I'm comparing two
different openings which I like to do we
see this Bishop being terrible all the
time okay and and if a you give a
lecture I don't know when it was
oh yeah was an hour ago you gave a
lecture and then Darien's like e6000 on
g7 so terrible again that's a problem
England queen pawn openings but it
happens here to the dish upon b7 not the
most active in fact John was giving some
crazy variation with a bishop did that
and got to d5 that's pretty cool
okay you could draw some kind of a
parallelogram
alright so c4 and now if you go crazy
and you take on c4 letting the knight
attack your queen then you grab a free
pawn as we discussed in previous
positions when your pieces get attacked
and they can't retreat that's not good
and so your queen doesn't so good
because it want me to get off the board
and then if you have a lot of extra
Queens like we have here my comer gets
really confused so man it was awesome I
was playing a blitz game yesterday I
think or maybe I was dreaming anyway and
then I asked my opponent how many pawns
I was ahead or behind and they were
looking and then started crying and then
it was like I had seven ponds and
and then my cover is like off the board
there's one pawn so that was easy
yeah that's let's have my comer counts
so you're playing my comer put a lot of
pieces near the board that'll be like no
we don't do that yeah okay so you can't
lose your queen because that's that's
terrible
all right so the best move is to take
advantage of the opponent's previous
move in this position 94 is illegal for
two reasons the first reason you
understand second reason is I can take
it so it should be illegal okay after
see for now 94 is a good move so when
your opponent plays c4 and their problem
is on c3 you should play 19 for whether
it's legal or it's a bughouse game
putting on d4 so the computer or the
commentator is suggesting 96 to d4 which
I agree with but he played Rick a d8
because maybe he wants to give a file
later so you're going to try to do it
now okay it takes takes rook a5 rawr and
now this pawn has attacked a few times
mainly by the piece you forgot about
which was what's that yeah the high rate
of player knows the bishop on f1 yeah so
that pawn is attacked a lot and when you
take on c4 which you still shouldn't do
I'm still playing 9 c4 and now Queen
before doesn't lose the Queen but it
should because I play rugby 1 and then
you got this guy in this guy and this
guy and this guy and it's the worst yeah
then it's just terrible
okay but this is a good piece no I'm
just kidding
okay so he played would he play he
resigned now he played my favorite move
Bishop f8 yes and now this will confuse
most of you the bishop is attacking the
b4 pawn right that didn't confuse you so
he defended it yes no no he defended it
see if I doesn't defend it yeah c5 gives
white a space advantage but now you
don't win the pawn on b5 so yeah Karpov
was like I want to win the pot on be
fine okay
also c5 moves upon breaking my rule
never move pawns
so Bishop c3 okay yeah that's the rule
my rules
okay now he played 96 two moves too late
and now black wants to play Knight f94
as I discussed earlier with the class so
he played Knight to f3 and then that's
what happened takes takes now he plays
c5 and this is a good Bishop so earlier
black had a very good piece on f4 but
now black doesn't have a good piece
that's mainly how Karpov played though
played the middle game was his pieces
were good and yours aren't and the
problem now with winning this pawn for
free is that while this is attacked but
then you open up this Bishop so c5
actually kills both bishops both bishops
are bad ok 7 Queen a two defending the
rook and f7 is always being in to act
okay and then e 5 and only going to
cheat some more yeah then I'll do a
Nigel short I'll take your bad okay that
was a little crazy there alright now
it's time for counter play d3 Karpov
loves when you have counter play he just
calculates 30 moves ahead lets you Queen
and then mates you no no no now he
doesn't do any of that
so after d3 Karpov is like that pawns in
my territory I'll take that pawn so he
plays Rick a three car bombs very good
at retreating a lot of his retreats
unseen by his opponents repositioning
his pieces the better squares end up
that pawns a goner but we do have this
nice Bishop the class is like that
bishops not nice but they're not saying
anything because they don't want to know
what if it is nice and they're wrong
no it's not nice I'm kidding okay rip
their d2 yum yum yum ribbed e4 e5 Oh so
since the bishop isn't doing anything
we're going to play e6 if the bishop
goes to see a setting up for the next
game then our rook can infiltrate
although I would not allow you sex
I would like hold his hands down I'm not
letting apply e6 I've seen what happens
when you apply e6 I resign okay so they
give some moves that stop East six and
say whites winning for example this is a
funny variation takes takes takes o
night Fork
tank hate when that happens okay so you
play drip takes b4 because the rook is
well placed on b4 and then e6 you can't
like I play e6 then you might take on f7
okay takes rook takes what's funny is
this rook that went over here to annoy
you is not going to go over here and
annoy you right my rook my rooks crooks
go sideways so the white rook on a3 is
either go to a7 and win or e3 f3 g3 and
when the King has no defense this Bishop
is terrible all whites pieces are great
here comes the jontron tonight 94 you
were always playing f5 with black and
stopping that remember now you can't
play f5 so I mean in bughouse
okay so King h8 doubles up the rooks you
have to trade rooks man this is tough
now you are showing a game earlier that
Carlsen beef on and the end of that game
reminded me of the end of this game what
what I say who isn't it the same person
all right I've been Caruana okay so
Carlson was playing Cara wanna knock it
I'm not having us well maybe okay am I
having a stroke maybe okay I'm not sure
high rated now because Carlotta keeps
winning all his games Carlson is easier
to say alright so recap for I can't I
have to click on training now because
the games about to end now I was
complaining earlier but now I like this
Bishop no I'm just kidding ninety-four
Queen da Queen e5 check whoops
this is what happens when you see one
threatened and prevent it Knight f6 was
going to be annoying Knight g5 was going
to be annoying Knight d6 sleep like
Queens e8
and defends everything all squares are
defended right but the Queen was
defending the rook
so the rook wasn't under attack Queen e5
check was impossible so those threats
weren't seen because they didn't exist
Queen d8 like made those threats exist
sort of like at the end of the game
Cara wanna play tricky eight and then
he's winning everything yeah all right
and then Queen e5 check resigns because
the rooks hanging on on f4 obviously
yeah and what's funny is different than
a lot of other players usually when my
pieces are active there's sort of active
karpas pieces are always close to each
other active they're always like they're
always there's two knights - right yeah
they're always like working together his
opponent's pieces mathematically as far
apart as possible I did that I did it I
did I did drawings I talked math Larsen
now Larsen so that's as far as they can
be yeah so it's funny that one time
black had like good defense of
everything defending his Bishop
defending his rook although Queens sort
of in the corner then he put in the
center and then loses everything but
yeah if white plays Knight f6 or 95 or
96 it doesn't matter yeah so Queen da
check and he's like yeah it's resigned
so that was a three examples I had
several war of Karpov being white Andrew
Lopez and slowly improving his position
although if you're a supercomputer let
me see no no nope okay your
supercomputer like Komodo or stock fish
on with like 500 cores then these
advantages I move 2025 which look like I
had White's a little better they're like
yeah whites waiting they're just like
yeah like this is terrible for black
black had to play better earlier and so
people learn to play better by watching
these games then they could draw
sometimes okay but still a really dumb
idea if you're black against Karpov and
you decide I'm going to be slightly
worse and try to draw and then you get
outplayed because your pieces go to the
wrong squares COFF COFF and Karpov King
always has like everything around it
safe the ship on f1 you could ever put
them in check and black split should
ever makes any sense
so the one time I play the rule up has
i won but it didn't look like this you
can't see it it's a piece of like equal
they might put of one gram 37 or
something that because I don't know I
don't know how to like do this and this
and this and this of this yeah and
that's why Karpov was good for such a
long time and it's still good agreed
yeah and after I show these games the
Karpov what did he say
carpeaux doesn't speak English
what so much better that we do anyone
somebody What did he say
class dismissed yeah of course